Thomas the last time I saw you you were
co-hosting ET Canada with me during the
pandemic and I just want to say thank
you
I'm pretty good at it thank you so much
I remember that thank you for having me
that day that was awesome yeah Katie you
need to come and co-host with me one day
too
oh I love it I love hosting anything
hostess with Moses
uh this song is so beautiful it's been
out there for a few months now from the
string Arrangement you guys performed at
the American Idol together you just have
this way of meshing together your voices
I mean what does it mean for you I know
Thomas is supposed to be a solo uh
project but then you have Katie part of
it no it's it's unbelievable it really
is I mean I know we talked about it
um a little earlier on in the year but
uh yeah I mean that I wrote that song
and kind of I didn't think twice about
it I was like this is this is what the
song is and I'm so thankful for people
um like my friend Allison at the label
who suggested we should we should see
about a feature and I was like who and
she was like I want to send this to Katy
Perry and I I literally laughed because
I was like she doesn't know who I am up
and you're sick of me saying this but
it's the truth no I like this you gotta
get my finger out here but um but no
when Katie hopped on the song like it
literally took it from like good good to
amazing and uh getting to have done it
on American Idol was such a dream come
true and getting to perform at the CMAs
is going to be I'm really excited I'm
excited just to be a part of country
music and be back in Nashville I was
here when I was 16 kind of cutting my
teeth and learning my chops
um and yeah when they sent me that song
I've been sent a lot of songs in my life
right
um and of course I don't do well all of
them every once in a while a song will
strike me and I'll be like oh I I
resonate with it this one was so
authentic I felt like I wrote it I felt
like it was telling my story and I felt
like if I resonated with it so many
other people can resonate with it and
it's it's just like a celebration of
gratitude for how far you've come even
you know when Even in our lives we don't
have good days sometimes but you can
pause and be like gosh I've done so much
and and you know have so much to show
for it and so much love and so much
family and it's just like amazing what
you you know the longer you live life
the more gratitude that's right for me
and it's so good to hear Katie that the
fact that you do take the time to kind
of reflect on your journey I mean from
where your humble beginnings just
started to Las Vegas residency what does
it mean for you to be able to create
music that speaks to so many people out
there
I love people I mean speaking of my my
speaking of my um residency sometimes
I'll just catch a Southwest flight home
from Vegas and just be like on the plane
the last time I was on the plane someone
got like dragged off I was like oh I've
seen videos like this
um and I'm actually in it right now but
they don't know that I have my hoodie on
and I got my mouth but like I just love
like watching people how they are how
and and like just you know how they
communicate the relationships I'm such a
people person I can have a conversation
with anyone for super long
um and I just love I love I love people
because I just like want the best for
them and so you know if I can help
Inspire anyone through my story uh kind
of coming from nowhere to creating this
world then I'm I'm happy to do that you
know sure
I love that and when you guys created
this video that was the first time
really meeting each other and I
understand you guys talked about
Parenthood because that's the first
thing we all do right is talk about our
kids
there were multiple times filming there
were multiple times filling filming this
video where they were like all right
guys we're ready for y'all and we're
like deep into just like showing
pictures of our kids and like he had
just had a baby so his fourth baby right
yeah four babies she's got one I got one
you know just trading trading advice
trading tips but those first three
months after having a baby like no one
told me about and this is my first child
so I'm still like oh my God that this
happens but like no one tells you about
the first six weeks of having her first
child you're like
this is curry you gotta think about
yourself too and the baby you don't even
know what's going on with your body like
there's a lot going on and you're like
feeding in the same corner of the same
room for six weeks straight and you're
like will I ever leave this house
I do will they be okay for sure listen
my kids are 15 and 12. and it doesn't
get easier let me just tell you that
there's different kind of difficulties
I love it but what have you guys learned
about yourselves I mean you know your
kids are still young but is there
anything that surprised you about you
being a parent
man I I think that my patience level has
gone way up and then for that I'm very
grateful
um my kids have my kids have retaught me
joy to be honest with you a hundred
percent like I thought I used to get
really pumped about stuff but like when
you watch your kids get pumped about
something that is super simple like a
rainbow or like literally just just do
they call it rainbow no but yours mine
calls it rainbow yeah but yeah I mean I
don't know I'm just like taking my kids
like outside for them to see nature like
they just get super jacked about seeing
a butterfly and you're just kind of like
so yeah you're right that's that's
really cool so Daisy you want to go and
get a cafe like a coffee
she's all about like this most mundane
for sure things it's you're you're right
it is just like you get this surge of
Joy back and it just makes everything
come to life for me it I've learned a
lot about presence you know and that was
something that I I really wanted to to
give as a mother is just like yeah
there's a zillion WhatsApp Chats on fire
but I'm like I'm gonna put this down and
I'm gonna color with you right now for
30 minutes right because I love you all
right I feel that you know what I'm
saying for sure
Katie how would you do babysitting for
Thomas for kids
they would love me actually they would
love me but they would also be like you
would probably y'all would probably hate
me I was never called to babysit because
I was the one I was like my sister's the
most responsible she's older but um
sometimes if my sister wasn't available
like they'd take a chance on me but I
was the kind of babysitter that the kids
would fool and be like yeah her mom
totally lets us eat these oranges like
seven o'clock at night I was like okay
well can I have one too and then like
and then okay guys well when the garage
door starts opening we're gonna run into
our beds yeah and so the garage door is
there so it'll be like everybody Katie
would be like my kids grandparents like
just saying yeah everything yes yes so I
love that uh your Las Vegas Vegas
residency first of all I just want to
say congratulations I don't know how you
did I don't know how how many shows you
did but how are you feeling coming out
of it and announcing that you're doing
it again
what did you learn from all of it
I was telling I was telling Thomas
actually the healthiest I am is when I'm
in Vegas and I'm the opposite excuse me
I don't Thrive there oh well by the way
I'm so glad I didn't have a residency in
my 20s right it would have been like
hello darkness my old friend right
um but now I'm 38 and I have that
balance that I needed in life and that
unconditional love and you know I just I
I'm doing what I love and having so much
fun with it and I love the show so much
and people love it and so I was like
well I'm not just gonna put it put all
these massive props you know I have a
20-foot toilet you just can't throw that
in your story I can't I gotta keep that
keep that plumbing work when that is
done I would like to I would like to buy
that oh I will put it on a flatbed track
and you will see a Flatbush
and put Christmas lights yes
very easiest toilet oh my gosh I know
and that whole thing with the eyelash
the the robot movement thing you did
like all these different theories that
like eyelash glue have you seen it
Thomas like oh yeah
right now
I'm showing him I like have all these
party tricks
oh man actually I learned it because
I've been sitting in a hair and makeup
chair because you're only as good as
your Glam for like 13 years and so I
would always watch my makeup artist
doing my face so I would watch like one
one eye is doing Shadow and I'm like
okay I'm watching you do my brow and
then and then I'd switch and below I
just I'm a freak you're right that's one
thing for certain about if one thing's
more certain about all of the theories
is I am a Frank
I am a freak like yes do that I love
that I love that and Thomas you're going
on tour next year too
yeah we are we're kicking off in Canada
in February
um which should be really cold and
exciting um we start in Vancouver and go
uh all the way over to Toronto and and
our North American date starts in in May
so looking forward to it it's gonna be
awesome and before that you're on the
CMA Awards as you mentioned that you're
going to be on stage is a different
performing in front of your colleagues
compared to your fans do you prepare
differently for it
we were talking about it you take beta
blockers right no okay no I do not I
don't know what that is
um no it is different because like I
don't know when you're when you're
playing like like a normal show like
yeah a tour date it's like you and your
band just have it so dialed you know
what I mean like there's room for people
that like love you I love you yeah and
like your peers love you too but it's a
little bit of just like hey blow me away
right now you know what I'm saying
um but we were just saying it's all like
I just like to find a few people in the
crowd that I know really well and
perform to them lock eyes with Luke
Bryan and be like you're gonna like this
you know
um but it is different like uh there's
more pressure I feel like when you
perform on television
you get one go at everything but there's
something about the one go that is being
presented to like millions of people
that I maybe is yeah it's nerve-wracking
you know we've gone through so much over
the last two and a half years and we've
come out and very strong are you guys in
a good place and happy and and just
enjoying life now
for sure yes we are we are we're
enjoying life it did take us I mean 2020
was strange for everybody obviously yeah
and I think the first six months of like
covet I was like what are we doing like
how do we whatever and now this
apocalypse yes and and now I feel I feel
like every everything just feels like
alive again which is really exciting
starting to yeah that's great I mean I
had a baby during that time so it was
also different it was a whole different
time you know it's just it was wild it
was wild there's a lot to be grateful
for yeah and to look back just like this
song where we started and to look back
at like how far you know you've come and
and some days when you have those down
days you can remind yourself like look
at all the beauty that you've created in
your world from your family to your
career to your friends the influence the
impact it's it's profound you guys are
lovely I love you Katie I'm looking
forward to you co-hosting with me okay
I'll see you soon I'll be there okay bye
love you both bye